John Stewart show got cancelled the
problem with John Stewart uh Apple
canceled it apparently because of some
of uh the content related to AI in
China so what I heard is John Stewart is
a goat by the way he's the
absolute goat uh what I heard is he was
okay with them asking him not to
criticize China because he's like all
right I get it fine a lot of your
products are made over there it's a
spiteful government whatever I get it
I'll pull back on that then when they
asked about the AI criticism he was like
you know what you I don't need this
you're not going to sit here and police
my my material that's just not happening
yeah wow it's is so fire dude yeah I
love that and I get I get him I get him
not doing the China piece
because he's agreeing to do a show on
Apple yeah so it's like if you're you
know that you're in bed with apple who's
in bed with China so it's are you really
going to be critical of them you're
supporting the brand you're building the
brand yeah right so I get him going all
right that I I could potentially be
hypocritic
also so cool of him to have that self
awareness be like I'm give you that one
who am I yeah but then you know John
Stewart's in the I don't need your money
land he's got you money but there's
a lot of people in that land that still
take the money and I don't judge them
because I could end up being one of them
if I had that kind of money but John
Stewart to truly be like now this is my
ethic and I'm not going to with
that I'm out now question details of the
AI story no I don't know was it
something he did do or something that he
I think wanted to do yeah now here's the
question I'm sure like John Stewart is
like the most caring dude like he's
dedicated his post The Daily Show career
to like getting Health Care to the
firefighters that were you know affected
by not allow like this guy clearly cares
about people the burn pits thing he
talked about on his show he's the man
now I wonder how difficult it was for
him to stop the show knowing that there
are probably all these people working
for the show that depend on it like I
wonder if if he's like uh I can't be be
censored and just become like a
propaganda arm for Apple but at the same
time there are all these people I
really love and believe in that
rely on this that's a good point but I
think it's going to be a crazy bidding
war for that show oh so you're saying
the show won't stop it will just go
somewhere else like hey we'll let you
say whatever you are Netflix now's your
time bro nfx now is your time I mean
look at like uh great John John Oliver
yeah he's with HBO yeah and they gave
him so much more money it's on YouTube
you can watch all of it for free yep
like yeah I mean if I'm Netflix I go
okay let's compete with HBO let's go
yeah put up put it on YouTube get the
money yeah also another cool story about
John one of our friends wrote for him on
another project that he John decided not
to move forward with it was supposed to
be like an animation thing and the
technology wasn't there he thought about
his employees and then he just paid them
out for an extra like I don't it was
like way more than what the standard is
like here you guys this will give you
time to figure out what you want to do
he just paid them so like he's the
goat what I was wondering you
know who still needs a host for their
show The Daily Show does he come back oh
that I mean imagine yeah even if he
guest hosted for a month it'd be the
craziest The Daily Show needs him really
really bad that would be awesome yeah
that would be so cool and then
immediately reestablishes it as the
brand that it used to be yes that would
be so cool Daily Show get on it
or if he runs for president oh Jesus my
vote
I don't think he wants to do politics
because he can't I he probably feels
like he can't be the honest good person
that he is I feel like you know that's
part that speak to his character but he
he goes to Washington and he speaks like
he he's trying to make change political
what I'm saying that'd be interesting
yeah also you sign up at price.com and
use the promo coach Schulz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100